ready ah action
[Music]
when we start secret Invasion Nick Fury
has been off planet and Maria Hill has
just really been trying to you know
maintain order but this current threat
is getting out of control
and it comes back having lost
whatever power he had before I'm
corjandro I'm here with the real rejects
sitting down with the director of all of
secret Invasion Ali Salin how you doing
today man great how are you I am
obsessed with your show so I'm very well
wow thank you I've loved each girl since
I was a kid so you've really done honor
to my childhood I appreciate it
fantastic so from knowing you're working
in treatment I noticed immediately this
amazing dual scenes between these two
actors that feels like they're dueling
these Great Character work pieces what
was the process like in rehearsal what
was it like playing on set with these
powerhouses who are you referring to uh
with Sam and Don Cheadle Sam Olivia yeah
yeah everyone's just got these these
scenes great scenes great really well
written scenes long scenes meaningful
scenes and you know all actors are
different in terms of what rehearsal
means to them and how they want to
approach it and my job was to sort of
balance those different needs right
Olivia has very different needs than Sam
and Sam has very different needs than
Olivia and they were very excited to
work together and so my job is less
about what do I do for them and how do I
create an environment where the both
work a lot of times people say how did
you learn how to direct and I say from
coaching Little League because I had 12
different people with 12 different needs
and I had to you know get them all to
hit the ball I had to pinch myself many
mornings when I would step on set with
Olivia Coleman Sam Jackson Don chill
Emilia Clark Ben Mendelson Kingsley
benedir I mean some of my favorite
actors in the world Marvel's always cast
really well but I feel like some of
these scenes are some of the best in the
whole MCU and seeing Ben Mendelson get
the flex and seeing a lot of this work
and I've also loved The Duality and
dichotomy of the Scrolls whether it's
the color palette or the use of some
language the the way their antagonist
and protagonist and I feel like the show
really mirrors that with literal mirrors
with your use of purple and green colors
with blue and red there's all this
imagery of Duality how intentional was
that in previous or was that something
you put in the script like how did that
come about to visually use so much
dichotomy oh interesting I mean I think
it's a show about dichotomy and so every
step along the way that's what we talked
about the cinematographer
the production designer everybody talked
about how can you show two sides of
everything how do you show you know the
production designer is great about
talking about colors primary colors
secondary colors how do you put them in
how do you work them in the purple blood
is a great addition it's just a rule we
came up with that when they die their
their blood turns purple and it's great
because you know green and purple and
that's so distracting
uh
did I answer your question oh absolutely
I was wondering just it was from the
beginning and it was throughout the
whole team yeah it's uh you know you
read it in the script and then you're
like okay how do we visualize it okay
what references do we use okay which
production designer is going to bring
this to the table we get to jump into
Nick Fury's World which is very spy
versus spy the kind of grittiness the
locations the way it feels the way it's
written it's a thriller
the opening of this has to cover so much
because you've got Decades of lore
you've got the Scrolls being
reintroduced as antagonist now you've
got to cover a lot densely what was the
pressure like in being brought onto the
show to have the opening be that strong
for a new show with beloved characters
oh I don't feel any pressure oh great
yeah you just you you find a way to tell
the story that that makes sense and
ultimately that's all it is it's just
Clarity emotion purpose everybody
understands and then you've got that but
I it doesn't feel like pressure to me to
maybe for the fans you know you have to
you have to deliver something for them
uh and there is a certain amount of
pressure to do that but just in terms of
working with the actors no it's all just
storytelling
for years
you've been avoiding Earth
I have called for your help plenty of
other times and you've been pretty
content to let those calls go straight
to voicemail
yeah well
this is different and speaking of the
actors I feel like this is the deepest
we've dove into Nick Fury and I feel
like that with the emotional Resonance
of not only Captain Marvel but also it
feels like end game this feels like a
sequel to both of those things what was
the process of going through this with
Sam because I know he's a producer on it
as well what was the conversation was it
collaborative how long ago did you come
on and what's it been like working with
him on this character well I've been on
for 28 months which I don't think is the
whole run I think people have been on
this for five years four years
um Sam's great he's a collaborator he
knows Nick Fury better than anybody
knows Nick Fury but he doesn't know this
Nick Fury because he's never explored it
and so it was a great opportunity to be
able to explore it with him as Nick Fury
went home and Nick Fury went internal
and examined his fears and doubts and
demons and and Sam was very
collaborative he understood what was in
the script but he also brought a lot of
his own personal stories to it that were
that you see on screen he's telling him
it's really seen in the trains wonderful
brilliant this idea of who can you trust
that is really the heart of the show you
could be talking to somebody who have a
very close relationship with and then
you find out that that's not who you
thought it was
it becomes sort of a cat Mouse game that
we we build toward to the end of the
show my last question for you with the
Scrolls there's so much secrecy and one
of the big things in the comics years
ago was like Jessica Drew be revealed
and I love I love the show of what if
and what can they do did you have to do
anything like scream where you film the
fake thing or alternated things or had
something as a mislead for any of the
cast or crew is there anything you had
to double down on no we did we didn't
and I I
um we never felt like we were shooting
spoilers out in public right and we
never felt like we were shooting
spoilers that anybody on the set would
reveal so
perfect we know no decoy scenes amazing
you didn't have to
you can't predict it and you can't
preempt it and you can't fathom it until
it happens I'm Nick Fury even when I'm
out I'm here well I adore the Scrolls I
love what you've done this is the most
mature Marvel show I think I've ever
seen and I love these characters since I
was a kid so I really appreciate it
thank you looking forward to hopefully
things getting super with the Scrolls
and the way you've set things up to feel
plausible in this world is so
appreciated thank you have a great day
fewer
Since You've Been Gone
thank you
things have gotten much worse
oh you think I came back
[Music]
you're in no shape for this fight that
lies before us
friend
this is personal
very few of us know about the wars
fought in the shadows that have raged on
this planet
you feel responsible
where are the Avengers
this war is one I have to fight alone
you're the most wanted man on the planet
you don't know what they have planned
for you
the Great Neck Fury
one last fight